she may be tiny and adorable but
Christina Aguilera's one-year-old
daughter is already giving her big
brother a run for his money
climbing everything time in the wall
must be just like her parkouring brother
you know I'm gonna have a heart attack
the boys coach couldn't help gushing
just a little bit about her baby's
summer rain and sharing her love of
fashion with the next generation it
really is so fun but I also like like
putting like pink converse and stuff you
know what I mean like like the sneakers
and like I totally have max hand-me-down
my friend my older son yeah to get to
her cuz there's nothing cuter than like
just with this like keep on hair and big
blue eyes and then like you know she's
she's she's very girly but then to dress
her up in like boy gear is it's so cute
so tough girl yeah one of my favorite
things about watching you this season is
you are so fearless and fun and all of
your fashion choices and your glam
you're always bringing something
different when do you feel most sexy oh
my god when I can take all of it off and
I'm gonna be in my bathroom oh natural
yeah totally yeah it is on that row but
I love dress up you know you can tell
from my video work and and my tours and
circus experiment like everything from
my past like I love the the essence of
theatrics and dressing up and all of
that though when I can have fun with it
and not take fashion links so seriously
like it should be like a popularity
click I hate when it be feels like that
and it feel it should feel like
theatrical and fun and artistic